I wish you were my enemy Nick Kroll
because that's too late listen No but
listen to me hear me out on this sleep
about this on the way over you've got
such an a great last name for an enemy
cruel yeah because because if if you
were always uh if you were my Nemesis
and you were constantly doing things to
me getting me I could go
cruel I mean isn't that a great last
name if you want I can live across the
street from old old Mrs Conan in a house
and then I can peer out and go oh I'm
just like a Jimmy goldstein-esque
character throwing massive parties like
weird loud DJ'd parties I'm wearing like
Rhinestone Cowboy outfits uh-huh that's
what you would do it is truly I saw him
I went to a Lakers game last night so do
you guys know Jimmy Goldstein James
Goldstein he's one of the great looking
men in the world he's the guy at every
basketball game who's wearing like uh
like a Rhinestone Cowboy
I've seen him I didn't know that was his
name yes and he owns that crazy house
that super mid-century like layer that's
in I don't know like a lot in her house
in bigger yes yes that's his house he
owns that what is he what is his claim
to fame other than having the coolest
clothes he goes to like every basketball
game and they all know him and like him
and he flies everywhere he's at almost
every game everywhere the next time
you're watching a basketball game you'll
see Jimmy be great if he had no money
yes it's just I mean none and he was
constantly
scamming the money to get just in the
door and to buy a few rimmore rivets for
his pants well that's why I'm that's why
I want to be your old Mrs Conan's
Nemesis Kroll who lives in a what's a
lavish massive loud parties but he's
always coming by to borrow money from
you Conan the Barbarian used to yell
about who is it uh there was a whip
there's a movie called Crow this Crow
k-r-u-l-o right but but Conan the
Barbarian goes scrum yeah and um I mean
so I just crawl it feels to me like that
would work for me I want to make sure it
works for you first off
well your concern should be yeah I mean
here we are you know you need a friend
uh apparently yes
if you think my closest friend is Marty
Short and that you can go online and
watch him destroy me in a super cut
would you ever do a follow-up podcast as
coroner brand needs an enemy and it's
just me and you just yeah and you're at
you every time
time and we're just you'd be down with
that that's a garlic idea that's a
fantastic idea I'm here for it yeah I am
available I am unfailingly you just
stare into him yeah but also reasons
yeah and and reasons why you do think
you'd make a great enemy and just you
know your long-standing hatred for me
and just all kinds of things you intend
to do to me to take me down how would
crawl open that little script for the
intro this show
um hi my name is Nick Kroll and I feel
great about being Conan O'Brien's enemy
here's why over the next 46 podcasts
you will hear
arrived at this moment
the mystery survolving the enemies that
I have inside of Conan's universe